[Music]
no what is this sleeping withy socks I
can't if I'm not next to a body of water
my feet needs to be covered I'm sorry
wait what if I'm not if I'm not in the
water meaning like on the beach or by a
pool and my feet can touch the water I
need to cover my feet like my feet
cannot be always I always wear socks Oh
I thought you so I cannot I mean I I I I
sleep naked did you ever do this thing
where you get hot in the night though
and you have to kick them off well the
the like in the middle of the night you
get hot and then you kick them off and
then I put them back on no I kick off I
kick off the the the blanket but the
socks yeah the socks stays on yeah see I
keep the blanket kick off the socks and
then I put the back on in the morning
cuz I'm cold yeah we're weird yeah I
mean I yeah uh yeah I mean I was just
thinking that I I I do clip my my
toenails you know so it's not about it's
not about like hiding my feet you know I
mean it's not like I'm like gnarly you
know like my dad was in was was in the
military so you know like like like like
like like clean nails are important you
know yeah and polish Su I'm like trying
to hide mine right now I'm like I don't
know what mine look like right now but
yeah mine always stay clean too um I'm
hiding them yeah well look they're just
very basic like whatever okay last one
this is Edgars go
ahead
obession what is this winter hats shaped
like animals I mean you got to have some
fun right wait
so well uh it's I just like w like
winter hats with like animal chick like
with funny like funny I guess like like
a actual oh there you go yes and you
look like you're having a good time well
you know well you know well you know
well you know what that's that pictures
pictures do likee I was having such a
bad time I was so sick when I took that
picture so sick and I was having tea I
was having this Argentinian uruan U mate
tea yeah for the Argentinian is that
really good for you when you're sick
it's really good when you're sick it's
good for everything yeah it's really
good and um and I was wearing yeah my uh
how do you call that frog that frog a
frog about caramel carel yeah we're
going to call him we're going to call
him Carmel though yeah
car the accent yeah I love it I love it
okay those are our
Obsession be sure to watch show Dr Death
on
PE
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home